what's up everybody it's gary
vaynerchuck I'm here in Chattanooga
Tennessee home of one of Benavidez five
offices and when you compare it to New
York LA San Francisco and London I think
it speaks volumes to my belief our
collective belief of what's going on
here in Chattanooga we're standing
outside the tomorrow building it's why
I'm making this random video with d-roc
today I saw it show it to everybody yeah
make sure that it makes it so that's
what's going on right cool so that's
next a little update tell Jordan has
lots of pants Jordan I mean that made
what up it look like the most gangster
[ __ ] ever this is great right you Zack
leaves on fire but I've read zero books
this year I've read like seven books in
my life like so I don't read I tell
people that I'm half Garrity half DJ
Khaled I launched a social media
marketing business OTD Mike if you're
half me and half DJ Khaled you're one of
the great human beings of all time so
looking forward to watching you ascend
to greatness
Hey what's cooking no this one's
unbelievably better I want you to look
at it you're 100% right
on the other side when you when people
think that literally what ends up
happening is we have the most
inefficient machine we have three cooks
in the kitchen we waste money and time
so that's why getting kind of like a
telepathic Understanding between the
leaders on business is the Holy Grail
what up snapchat I'm fired up
do you rock is here focus [ __ ] you I
mean you know that's that's what we do
for a living we sell time right so we're
going there we're coming back we're
gonna do the thinking and then we cut
and then I come with you guys to Kansas
City and we present for two three hours
and then I give a talk and that's what
the that's what that's kind of like the
scope is you know and then uh and then
that's it you know have a good rest of
the day guys thank you thank you
what's up Alabama this is the coolest
[ __ ] I've ever seen
did you did you just literally did you
literally just think it was gonna be
okay
I'm really trying to understand you know
so what's happening on its what am i
doing am i doing a keynote am i doing QA
with you love it I'm asking you for 60
minutes I don't want to see a single
question I'm so pumped
beautiful yes that's all I want to do it
makes it so much it's such a better
first ones a better product they can see
if you put me out there normal they can
watch that [ __ ] on YouTube now it's all
gonna be new [ __ ] yeah and then we can
get you a lot of exposure because we'll
use it and then like everybody's gonna
want to come to this and it's gonna be
interesting for my fan base because it's
gonna be new [ __ ]
plus it's braylon's you the whole thing
Mazel Tov I'll come back
Hey I kicked I warned you like you
crushed it I can spend some time with
you later yeah your face Josh yeah right
here yes show me some personality
I'm keeping the mic yeah anything so
pump to connect good nice grass here man
nice to meet you man yeah a real
pleasure
see you guys later ready it's great to
be here thank you so much there's always
a learning curve sort of Scout itself
teach yourself to be a heaven anchor by
doing it it's you know meaning I just do
it like you know like we know that
Pokemon go is happening right we know
what's happening right now you could say
it's a fad or it's stupid or who cares I
need to understand it not because I care
if Pokemon go we'll be here in three
years but because this is the coming-out
party for AR right and like a million
apps are being developed right now
literally all of the Silicon Valley is
sitting in boardrooms right now creating
their AR app and we're all gonna shop
and go to football games and do all
sorts of stuff through that environment
and so there's people in here that are
like I'm never gonna do anything with
pokemons go that's fine but you're gonna
do something with AR and so you need to
use it it's like trying to run a
marathon without prepping for it you're
gonna lose
respecting following its leaders because
you are a practitioner yeah I I stand in
front of those 500 or so 25 year-olds
and I'm like I'm the best that social
media in this room is right and I mean
it I and and that's because I use it
more than they do I mean they're using
it to hook up I'm trying to sell [ __ ]
you know IQ is decreased in value
because of technology but EQ is greater
than ever you know emotional
intelligence really really matters and I
look for that and anybody that I
surround myself with do you actually
have empathy and gratitude and
self-awareness and care and all these
warm and fuzzy things that I think are
the essential infrastructure to be
successful in business yeah you know I
just I
I'm gonna struggle to the day I die of
allowing yourself to look at glass
half-empty I just feel like I feel like
and now I understand it's DNA and it's
wiring and you know if you grow up with
a mother who's extremely negative it's a
really tough situation to break out of
it just proven I've understood you grew
up in a tough town I get it there's a
couple of issues with that number one
nobody cares that's the big punchline I
uh as long as the eight to twelve core
people in my life are healthy I struggle
to really get down I just don't know how
to do it and so when you live your life
that way losing a big account or
somebody calling you out is just not
that painful you just put it into
context I usually just like you know
like take it you know like you know what
me this is so interesting I think you
find this interesting my favorite scene
in movies is always when somebody gets
punched in the mouth and they take the
punch they spit their tooth out and then
they look back at the other person
I don't have you've seen that there's
always some version of that scene that's
who I am as a [ __ ] human being like
I'm built to get punched in the mouth
I'm gonna spit my friend mm I'm gonna
look right back at you and be like now
what [ __ ] thank you thank you so much
ma'am thanks guys sir thank you very the
posters are back here yeah this is
something I'm very used to I do that
felt great you know what I'm most
excited about I really think that's one
of the better you know it's not given so
that's gonna get a lot of a lot of views
over the next five years for you guys
thank you brother
all right well what is ours can I sign
I love the man Xerox
thank you brother how are you
to it
I love it
mrs.
that's amazing thank you very much
so Stacey comes to
Stacy it's time to [ __ ] work let's do
this one life Stacy one life love you
brothers are coming out
it's alright awesome man thank you
I won't Patrick Ewing so much you guys
are unbelievable how to type of your
bank you know where so listen it by
thank you thank you
for the day yeah we just put that in
there
what is it now 2016
thank you thank you
time to go you need to come to them and
say look I need to know you because then
I can make it better for you so some
people want you to rah rah rah
I'm gonna look straight ahead and be
like a [ __ ] idiot but you know and
listen oh well I I know you know even
better than I do oh half of like I said
in there half a [ __ ] Silicon Valley
right now it's sitting out and
whiteboarding there AR a bunch of [ __ ]
thought but and you know this and this
happen with social for you know there
for every snapchat and Facebook there
was plenty of clerks there's another
there's plenty of it so you're right
there'll be plenty of [ __ ] but there's
some [ __ ] seventeen-year-old badass
he was thinking who's thinking I'm gonna
build a neck snap chat and now what he's
gonna do is I can use this and build
something meaning
so I launched winelibrary.com 96 kid was
born I mean yeah suddenly we're gonna
see you that maybe you didn't see you go
and execute build it from here to the
next level then it feels real so
everybody in this community needs to
help each other because if one player
wins in this market all of you are gonna
be impact and that's the thing is many
of these markets learn Silicon Valley
until somebody plowed until the land and
made it happen make me feel
nice it's just uh oh I'm sorry
you know I'm in a pretty spot I'm trying
to analyze obviously I've made a real
commitment to Chattanooga Tennessee and
obviously it's already close to here but
like Vayner sports like I could see
maybe even opening I want to really get
to know this tech community and I want
to get to know you because this is the
kind of place where I could see opening
a Bader sports office because I mean
let's call it what it is or in this
environment I mean in the same way that
if I had to go to Silicon Valley to meet
Scoville and all those guys when I
decide to go into pet if I'm gonna be
recruiting college football players this
is this is a capital I'm going to change
the game I know you do because you know
enough about what I thought this is what
I do so I'm very excited because you
know wine I loved because it was the
vehicle for my business passion
marketing I loved but like AJ my
brother's said the best thing he said I
said I just talked to the other day I go
so what do you think about the spate of
sports thing he goes it's a lot more fun
to sell a six foot two safety than it is
a bottled water
I think comes down to my big thing is
you got to pay attention and even be
present in a lot of ways not just
physically
I think it's mental ward anything else I
speak to my kids a lot like when I have
far less time I think that most people
it's unbelievable how much I talk to
them it's because I'm so I'm a lot which
is wherever I am is where I am it's why
you guys like it so much when it comes
at the expense of at home on the flip
side when I'm home I'm not locked into
this right that's just real
like it's like there's nothing else
going on in the world right now but he
ate it
you know what guys I want to say
something right now getting a little bit
on a bigger plane what's happening right
now is the small minority of people that
are mad and angry and painful and dark
are much louder than the big percentage
of us that are happy and excited and
feel great and because the way
technology works they are much louder
than they've ever been before
if you leave with anything for any of us
please please take on the sense of
responsibility that if you've got good
and you feel good to start sharing that
content as well because the world needs
more of it
thank you darling good day
good Birmingham Alabama
you